قناه الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني حسن
نصر الله ان فريقه السياسيه اريد رئيسا
للجمهوريه مطمئنا للمقاومات واضاف نصر
الله في كلمه متلفزه انها على الرئيس
اللبناني القادم عدم الخوف او ان يكون
يباع او يشتري وفق تعبيره
مطمئنا لهذه المقاومه اول شيء ما يخاف
مش اذا سرقوا عليه بالسفاره الامريكيه او
بالخارجيه الامريكيه او بالقياده
الامريكيه الوسطى فضلا عن لاعلى منهن ببلش
يرجف ويخاف ويتنازع
بدنا رئيس شجاعه
الوطنيه على خوفه
واثنين بصراحه اكثر بدنا رئيس لا ينباع
ولا ينشره
وهكذا نصر الله في كلمته ان لبنان يتعرض
لحصار امريكي يمنعه من المساعدات
تستخدم قانون قيصر ذريعه لمنع وصول
المساعدات للبنان
من الذي يمنع حتى الان مجيء الغاز المصري
الى لبنان
من الذي يمنع حتى الان وصول الكهرباء
الاردنيه الى لبنان
هو اللي عامل قانون قيصر
الذي يمنع المساعدات لبنان
ان تخرج على الحصار الامويكي وتمد يد
المساعده الى لبنان شو بيجو الامريكان
بيعملوا بيجو للدوله اللبنانيه للحكومه
اللبنانيه ممنوع تاخذوا المساعده